this video is brought to you by
brilliant.org
[Music]
hey wisecrack it's brainy jared here
helen and today
we're talking about the first season of
one of the most cerebral animes out
there
psycho pass
and it's amazing set in a dystopian
japan where
everything is controlled by a seemingly
omniscient computer the civil system
psychopaths asks some pretty hefty
questions namely is it possible for a
computer to determine
everything about us
[Music]
and more importantly would we want to
live in a society without free will
well as it happens this question isn't
just about philosophy but also
science so sit down shut up and let
disembodied helen explain how the civil
system just might suggest that free will
is a neurological and societal illusion
in this wisecrack edition on the science
and philosophy of psychopaths
and q sirens that's what we do with
spoilers right
also covering all the sexy smart stuff
in this series would be impossible to do
in one video
so if you want to hear jared break it
down some more let us know in the
comments
first a quick recap for the uninitiated
in the world of psychopaths
the sybil system determines everything
about you from your job to the
likelihood that you'll commit a crime
all by constantly scanning your brain
and keeping you under surveillance
this handy-dandy all-encompassing
reading is called your psycho pass
and it's what the civil system uses to
make all its decisions about you
[Music]
inspector at the criminal investigations
department or cid
it's kind of like being a cop except
instead of following the law
you're following the system's directions
and instead of police dogs you get
enforcers
who are basically would-be criminals
that the system has granted limited
freedom to in exchange for
well not a lot
now you might think that a legal system
based off a computer scanning your brain
is some minority report level bull
you have free will so you shouldn't be
arrested before you actually commit a
crime right
well let me stop you right there a
psychopath illustrates it's not quite
that simple first we have to understand
what the brain
and the decision-making process really
is
most neuroscientists today think there
are two systems in the brain
the first system is us that little voice
in our heads
those emotions we feel all those
thoughts we think
it's the stuff we're actually aware of
when we make a decision
this is the system where we like to
think it happens but that's not entirely
the case
below this system is another system a
huge latticework
of neurons that controls everything from
spatial processing to breathing
importantly this second system is a
black box no matter how much armchair
philosophizing we do
we can't penetrate it and this is where
the science of free will comes in
see in the 1980s dr benjamin labett
conducted a pretty groundbreaking
experiment
he asked subjects to look at a clock
then at a time of their own choosing
flick their wrist lebet then recorded
the electrical impulses from their brain
called the readiness potential and
compared it with the time the subjects
believed they made the decision to flick
their wrist
the results readiness potential preceded
the subject's awareness of making the
decision
by about half a second in other words
the decision to flick their wrist
happened somewhere in the unconscious
system about half a second before they
thought they made the decision
kind of like thunder following lightning
and while lebet's experiment wasn't
without flaws
like how he relied on self-reporting
it's important to note that other
researchers have borne out similar
results in experiments that were better
controlled
while we can't say for sure that there's
a causal relationship here
we can say that on some level it looks
like the decision-making process begins
in this unconscious part of the brain
which makes you wonder are we really
completely in control of the choices we
make
and if we're not how can we say they're
ours lebet's experiment goes a long way
in making sense of psychopass's world
after all why would anyone let a
computer make preemptive judgments about
them
ordering every facet of their lives well
because a very smart computer like the
civil system can
have a deep understanding of the brain's
black box in a sense knowing us better
than we know ourselves
hell the system knows the inner workings
of the unconscious mind so well
that it can even identify likely
criminals as toddlers
in a sense the relationship between the
civil system and its citizens is
parallel to the relationship between the
two systems in our brain
the citizens mull about with all their
feelings thoughts and seeming choices
while literally thousands of feet below
their feet is a vast network of sensors
processors and fiber optic cables all in
charge of controlling them
but if our unconscious mind is affecting
our conscious decisions
we have to wonder what then is affecting
our unconscious mind
if we hear subliminal messages saying
love logan paul
are we actually going to like him
unsurprisingly the civil system takes
the question of what can affect its
citizens minds
very seriously the system is practically
obsessed with keeping the mental states
of its citizenry squeaky clean
so much so that it measures the stress
levels of public spaces
constantly imagine walking around the
mall peacefully minding your own
business when
bam your psychopath reading changes and
this guy comes up to you
with this obsession of keeping its
citizens healthy it's also not
surprising that the system will also
black out the press
for the public good
and it goes without saying that other
forms of expression like
music and art are also limited this is
pretty much an orwellian nightmare of
the first degree
but is the sibyl system wrong to control
freedom of speech
as frightening as it may sound science
at least
might say no as it turns out human
beings are world class imitators
we're so good in fact that we do it
innately without even realizing it
research performed by andrew meltoff has
shown that infants imitate even the most
ludicrous of actions
14 month olds for example will do dumb
like use their foreheads instead of
their fingers to turn on a touch sensor
light
simply by watching an adult do it now
there's evidence to suggest that
children are such good imitators because
the parts of their brain that control
inhibition aren't fully developed
but just because we're not wearing
diapers doesn't mean adults are any less
likely to imitate their peers
in fact humans are so susceptible to
imitation that just perceiving an action
performed by another person
will drastically increase the likelihood
of them emulating it
this is called the chameleon effect and
it has to do with a special set of brain
cells called mirror neurons which fire
when we watch
others perform an action this goes on
during all of our interactions without
us
ever noticing it and that's the key
takeaway it happens
automatically and subconsciously it
happens in that impenetrable system of
our brain
so why would the civil system need to
crack down on crime before crime happens
because behavior is contagious and that
means everything from laughing to
violence
and when we're exposed to the latter
even in the regular world
there are consequences and this seems to
be the case in the world of psychopaths
when the city
is flooded with low-grade criminals
wearing helmets that stop the civil
system from reading their psychopaths
we see violence spread to the normal
citizens with an almost gleeful
contagion
foreign
so whether it's in your brain or on the
streets it's clear that the civil system
is bent on removing agency from its
citizens
and this is where we get to the question
at the heart of psychopaths
what is the value of living in a society
without free will
it's exactly this question that drives
shogo makshima this first season's
antagonist
makshima is driven to test the value of
free will in a society where it's been
rendered meaningless
[Music]
[Music]
a page from wisecrack favorite emmanuel
kant who believe that you can only be
moral by following moral laws out of
your own free will
and makshima goes to insane lengths to
see the worth of people's will
enabling criminal after criminal who
wants to test their will against the
system
but makshima is the baddie so does that
mean akane believes the opposite
is she the sybil system's number one fan
going all in for the belief that free
will
must be squashed for the greater
collective good well
not really throughout the series akane
displays a unique sense of individualism
she was such a good student that the
system determined she'd be a good fit in
literally any industry
and after she joins the cid akane early
on questions the merit of blindly
following the civil system's orders
and although she begrudgingly allows the
system to remain by the end of the first
season
she does so on her own terms
[Music]
in this sense akane represents a sort of
middle ground sure
maybe the unconscious mind or the civil
system influences her decisions
but ultimately they're still hers to
make despite reaffirming a system that
strips her of some
agency akane herself manages to preserve
the semblance of free will
but in the end akane can't actually stop
makshima
that role falls to kogami now we could
say a lot about why makshima values
kogami so much more than akane
but i think it has to do with this
[Music]
be
by letting the civil system dictate your
life makshima believes you stop becoming
an individual
without free will you're not a human but
merely a cog
in the machine maybe this is why kogami
the man who's willing to live as a
fugitive from the system in order to
stop makshima
is the only one makshima cares about by
the season's end
kogami is the only one who acts freely
and in this sense
he's the only one makshima has a real
relationship with in this world
what makes the world of psychopaths so
frightening is that unlike other shows
this dystopian society isn't the result
of paranoia or crisis management but of
scientific
progress so what do you guys think is
free will
all that great or even real or would we
all be better off letting a super
computer call the shots
personally i vote for free will in
letting computers only check email
to stay ahead brilliant.org will help me
train my brain through curated sequences
of fun arcade
style questions in logic linear algebra
classical mechanics artificial neural
networks and more
these modules test critical thinking and
analysis skills that could apply to the
real world
and if you want to learn more about our
future overlords i'd recommend their
module on machine learning which breaks
down how supercomputers succeed in
analyzing data where humans fall short
so develop your critical thinking and go
to brilliant.org
wisecrack to sign up for free the first
200 people that go to that link will get
20
off the annual premium subscription so
what do you guys think drop me a comment
and let me know
and as always peace that's how we sign
off right